il n'ya pour y faire je me permets de
vous poser une question peu particulier
en problèmes de l'île de france
les zones urbaines
grice considérablement est ce que les
agriculteurs semblent se préoccupent
justement de ce problème et sont
inquiètes ce les agriculteurs s'en
préoccupent les pouvoirs publics
également il ya actuellement des
concertations qui sont en cours pour
permettre bien sûr la progression
urbaine qui est inéluctable tout en
sauvegardant ce qui est essentiel à la
fois aux agriculteurs mais aussi à
l'ensemble des zones urbaines c'est à
dire le maintien d'une agriculture qui
seule permet de maintenir les zones
rurales et donc les équilibres de ces
régions
abo
noélie doute c'est la plus belle à ces
gentils c'est votre plus que je pense
que notre cette année d'importantes
participations internationales et
notamment de la communauté est ce que
ceci veut dire que c'est une
concrétisation des efforts des
différents ministres de l'agriculture
que vous étiez n'ya pas encore ça veut
dire surtout que les éleveurs ont fait
un effort considérable à la fois pour la
qualité mais également pour
l'organisation il faut d'ailleurs se
poursuit et qui leur permettra sans
aucun doute d'en bénéficier
grâce à l'exportation qui compte
voir en fonction de l'effort biz
l'agriculteur fait qu accompagner ou
faciliter les choses le fond du problème
c'est que les éleveurs français sont
devenus certainement avec le mans les
meilleurs du monde et toutes les races
que nous voyons ici aujourd'hui témoigne
amplement je crois que personne ne peut
le contester
porte de versailles à paris jacques
chirac a inauguré ce matin le 34e salon
de l'agriculture
habitué des lieux lui même ancien
ministre de l'agriculture le président
avait passé près de cinq heures l'an
dernier à arpenter les travées du salon
reportage habitants baer jacques gregor
c'est une tradition avec ses figures
imposées ces centaines de mains serrées
ses conseils ses encouragements jacques
chirac est chez lui au salon de
l'agriculture
chaque année c'est le même rite
baby boomers
g
l'an dernier le chef de l'état a dépassé
5 heures au salon de l'agriculture de
loin l'inauguration qu'il préfère
pas moins de six cent mille visiteurs
sont attendus dans ce salon qui s'étend
sur 120 mille mètres carrés
il préfère inauguration et ouverture à
paris du salon de l'agriculture et le
président jacques chirac habitués
fidèles de la manifestation était bien
sûr au rendez vous des éleveurs et de
leurs préoccupations
le reportage de claude guaino et jean
jacques botti un bain de foule de deux
heures et demie jacques chirac n'a
certainement rien vu du salon de
l'agriculture pas plus les vaches
limousines que les charolaises mais
super serré beaucoup de mains d'un
millier demain dans une joyeuse
bousculade
les feuilletons fait le plus de mal
possible vous avez vu le président et
cet exercice laborieux pour le président
de la république a fait beaucoup
d'heureux et d'heureuses chacun
attendait son tour avec impatience
il est vrai que depuis son passage au
ministère de l'agriculture entre 1972 et
jacques chirac s'est fait beaucoup
d'amis dans le monde paysan toujours
chiraquien de toujours chirac un bal
folk faut demander aux autres je pouvais
vous mais moi j'y suis toujours là des
six non non non non on y croit encore
car le travail du président c'est aussi
de goûter les produits régionaux
impossible de refuser sous peine de
froisser son public maison consacrant sa
visite essentiellement à l'élevage bovin
le président de la république a aussi
tenu à manifester sa préoccupation pour
cette activité toujours très éprouvé par
la crise de la vache folle
ah oui on faire entre 1000 et 2000
enfants
une vague de réformes et justement en
mettant l'accent sur la qualité de la
viande
le salon de l'agriculture veut tout
faire pour rassurer les consommateurs
jacques chirac qui avait raté
l'ouverture du salon de l'agriculture
dimanche dernier pour cause de visite en
macédoine a rattrapé son retard ce matin
pendant quatre heures le chef de l'état
s'est promené au milieu des stands une
visite amicale mais surtout symbolique
pour montrer aux agriculteurs français
sa détermination à défendre leurs
intérêts dans les négociations sur la
réforme de la pac
roselyne febvre le terroir et la france
bien chez nous tout ce qui plaît à
jacques chirac
aux aurores ce dimanche matin les
visiteurs étaient déjà là appareil photo
et bras chargés de cadeaux
et comme à son habitude jacques chirac
aura serré une multitude de main
toujours accompagnée d'une même
attention pour chacun
d'ordinaire au salon de l'agriculture ce
sont les hommes politiques qui caressent
les agriculteurs dans le sens du poil
et cette fois pour le président de la
république s'était contraire accompagné
par le ministre de l'agriculture jean
glavany resté stoïque durant ce marathon
jacques chirac aura sur son chemin à
gurgy td milkshake frais du fromage du
saucisson et du vin de pays
il aura même baptisé des veaux avec
l'instit gérard klein mais il aura
surtout rassurer les agriculteurs sur
les négociations en cours sur la pac
mais les paysans français peut être
assurée
de la détermination de ma détermination
de celles du gouvernement à défendre
leurs intérêts légitimes qui sont
d'ailleurs les intérêts et justement cet
après midi l'allemagne annoncé qu'elle
acceptait que la pac reste financé par
la communauté européenne
le salon fermera donc ses portes ce soir
apparemment sous de bons auspices jo
il préfère il m'est plus président de la
république mais il est semble-t-il
président d'honneur à vie au salon de
l'agriculture jacques chirac était très
attendu aujourd'hui à la porte de
versailles
et vous allez voir qu'au contact des
animaux et des agriculteurs la bête
politique n'a pas perdu ses habitudes
reportage et landing samueli metz
attendu comme la superstar du salon de
l'agriculture que jacques chirac est ici
en terrain connu et annie toujours le
même salut jovial toujours le même
appétit toujours la même envie d'aller
au contact et tous mes voeux
la pomme devons tous les produits du
terroir sont à son goût ils sont les
meilleurs du monde
l'un stand à l'autre jacques chirac ne
boude pas son plaisir quand je vais au
second on me demande même pas ce que je
bois on m'a même tout de suite une
bouteille de bière passage par le stand
des dom tom
un petit verre de rhum et le voleur
partie d'un des bovins on n'avait jamais
de digestion mais j'aime beaucoup les
produits de la ferme
ici il marque sa préférence pour sa
terre d'élection
les normands que c'est très très bien ne
sais juste en dessous de l'émission
il ya toujours des proches de
l'agriculture
contrairement peut-être au président
d'aujourd'hui qui est un peu plus
né un bilan donc mais jacques chirac me
dire un mot sur son successeur
une règle qu'il s'est imposé depuis son
départ de l'elysée à propos du monde
agricole
il préfère railleuse vague il est
tolérant est une vertu cardinale dans
l'état clé chose ce n'est pas acquis que
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
premier ministre sérieux la politique je
crois que c'est clair
la politique c'est brutal et souvent
inhumains fait votre joli métier que
nous n'entendons sur ce point recevoir
de l'option de personnes qu'est ce qui
lui arrive à la donner pour faire
chauffer la part l ina politique
cliquez pour vous abonner faire